[Music]
oh hello
we're just arguing everyone um now um
we were gonna do an ad for a thing but
it's a long story um
bianca what have you been doing you know
every week you ask me listen every week
i
don't have an answer and i just defer
back to you you blank out i blink out
every time like i
i wrote i put mine on the list well i'm
going to start doing
that yeah because it's um it's on the
list it says tennis neal now neil what
does that mean
neil elaborate it means that
when neil has gone to thailand
for his vacation his holiday
uh christmas new year's tennis neil is
so funny
uh uh elaborate i don't spend money but
on new year's and christmas i'll
i'll blow i'll really blow her out and
uh
and and blast off and go to
asia and really pop it off and uh the
at one of the places i go to called
trisara
t-r-i-s this is a resume a-r-a yeah
insane prices for this [ __ ] insane
like where you're like [ __ ] you they
have a tennis
court and lessons and i take lessons and
i don't show it here much kind of
athletic
people wouldn't believe it but every
tennis coach i've had and they're not
just
they're not just uh going they're not
doing they're not you know woman talking
about penis
they actually have all said that i'm i'm
i have five brothers so i
we had to play sports so i played tennis
and i decided
to take a tennis lesson this past
saturday
and i liked it and i
really liked it beforehand yes santa
monica california
lincoln and um and wilshire if you want
to come watch next week
uh i have a nice forehand like most
people have a nice forehand
and my backhand looks like uh like uh
you hate to say [ __ ] person yeah
this is a separate thing that i should
have put on the list and i forgot
i was talking a friend of mine and she
was saying that
friends of hers her super woke friends
flag her whenever she says crazy or
insane
because that's the next round no i won't
give up
crazy well i won't it's hard enough for
the r word it's very hard
i know i know i'm still riding with it i
mean
off air uh but
so you have a good so you can't say
crazy and you can't say anything which
is a whole other
issue yeah uh yeah it's too it's
because it's disrespectful to people
with mental illness but they don't want
to be crazy either
bianca crazy is not a
is not a um [ __ ]
uh what's it called yeah an appraisal
it's not a diagnosis it's a it's an
adjective
for it's a lot of these are just
diagnoses from the 50s
right they're like [ __ ] was it just
a diagnosis
crazy diagnosis like you know hysterical
was
the diagnosis for women which i think
was
we should maybe bring back bring it back
um wait tell me more about this backhand
meal
well bianca with beforehand
the key with tennis that i didn't know
was you can't you watch
pros and they just looks like you do the
scream
um i'll tell it's one of my famous
serena stories after this
okay um you have to wait till the ball's
in right in front of you
and then you i was doing it way early i
was doing it like
yeah and you just end up doing moonshots
you wait till it's thing
and you put your left foot forward
another thing i did not know
okay left foot forward so it's way more
like
baseball or some [ __ ] or golf and then
backhand it's two hands which right
there is a problem
i do an interlock which i didn't tell
the teacher but that that stays here
stays on the podcast and then you
it's more mechanical like wait i thought
you're backhanding it
i am this is backhand the ball's coming
this way and i
boosh no i meant like this like
what do you think this is well i don't
know backhand it's backhand
i don't know it's backhand getting
confusing you're just you're getting
i'm getting i'm over here i'm scared so
my left hand
right it looks like your right hand
um yeah so if you hit a forehand it
would be to my backhand
if you put a backhand of being in my
forehand anyhow
anyhow honey let's not let's not get
hysterical shout out to the hysterics
uh that was enjoyable and i had to tell
off
i just scold two different groups of
people
one of them was the people who were
charging 75 a ticket for my show
and then adding a seven dollar ticket
fee to each ticket
and then charging 30 for a chicken
sandwich
and then adding a fee to that
a chicken feet a chicken sandwich fee it
was like what are you doing and the
guy's like well that's what we i
we don't have to be ticketmaster like we
know they were
evil and then everyone's like well it's
different one i no dude
a cartel is a cartel right there the
reason why they make that [ __ ]
is the reason why you're doing it to
make as much money as possible
they're not doing it there's not a
difference between a low
like a small group selling tickets and
ticketmaster if you're just charging a
[ __ ] ton of money in a service fee i
mean what is really a service
nothing it's it's like so what i always
want to say to banks
banks is going so let me get straight so
you guys have installed atms all across
the world and they're all computerized
and yet they you're going to charge me a
fee to deal with a computer but if i
deal with a human being
who has to sleep and poop and all that
other [ __ ]
yeah that's free right but the computer
so you guys would be losing money on
these things you're probably
it might these computers must cost you
40 grand a year based on what you're
charging me
my thing is bianca yes what i've always
thought
and then i have to wedge in this serena
story because i still haven't told it
and it's a b-minus tops uh
i have some money i don't want to gouge
the people that like me
yeah i just don't want to gouge the
people spade david spade actually wrote
on my instagram
thing if you want to get gouge come to
my show because
he doesn't care he doesn't care he just
doesn't he's from i don't know
i just feel like and he has way more
money than me
but i don't know i think he grew up
single mom
i think it's people get [ __ ] in them
that's like
i need all the money i can get right
like good people
are like no no give me the money yeah
but then i remember when louie would
come to the store
he would always sell tickets through his
website no services no service
yes but he would have people come
through and count that [ __ ]
yeah he's like no no i'm not making a
ton of money here so there's not going
to be making sure that people weren't
being shiesty
oh yeah or just okay like squeezing in a
bunch of people i was like no
because comedy club i've been doing
comedy clubs and one of the waitresses
whispered to me
they added seats like in
during like between shows
yeah so louie was very i actually
thought of that
an hour ago how moral louis was when it
came to tickets
and again he had some lapses in other
areas
serena williams one time told me bianca
that she would make noises
she makes more noises when she's losing
wow
yeah which is just funny she's like when
i'm losing i make noises
which is fun there's something funny
about that and if that's uh if that's a
story don't leak it
it's not a story she didn't scold
anybody and i scolded by the way i
scolded the guys who did all the
curtains
and because they because it took them
two months
yeah and the guy would it's it's
adam carol had a show called to catch a
contractor
oh my god which i heard i was like
that's the greatest idea i've ever heard
it was on some rinky-dink network and
never never went anywhere
but these guys are
above the law yeah oh i watched judge
judy i'm an avid
judy watcher and the amount of
construction workers that just didn't
finish the job
and guess what they're entitled to the
money they got not they let's say
let's say they got half so usually you
pay half
and then they spread out the payments so
by the
end of it then you get the final payment
if you've only gotten paid for half
and they only did half the work they get
to keep the money for some reason it
feels rude
it feels right it's it should be against
the law no it's not
because they did work but they didn't do
all the work
well they didn't get paid all the money
it's so funny
oh they it okay i wasn't listening
correctly they
so they don't get all the money they got
they didn't get the full amount they
don't get the full amount they get paid
but still it's like if you fit
on if you leave a job unfinished [ __ ]
you you shouldn't be able to get any
money
yeah the guy would it took [ __ ]
he would he would go hey you owe me this
and i'd be like i literally emailed him
but i go where do you get these numbers
from and then somehow when he'd go over
them
he'd take four hundred dollars off
because he didn't yes
twice because he knew i was like wait
what
so i finally he the guys and i told you
this off the air last week
that i could tell all the guys who d you
know when
they go i got to go to get a part
because they didn't know what the [ __ ]
they were doing to begin with yeah
so they would go i gotta go meanwhile
every one of the guys had never done it
had never done the thing he had the the
right the track for the curtains
he'd nev they had it in three pieces
so they weren't lining up and the thing
would catch and i could hear the guy the
other day going like
[ __ ] it was making me laugh so hard
because
he's like
[ __ ] it was like oh this is not good
neil's on angie's list like
i mean well by the way i'm not gonna say
what list i got
these guys on but a lot of times it was
they get them
they get they try these guys go on those
lists to
take to go off the list yeah to go hey
we don't get together
yeah well it's like gentlemen now now i
realize
i have no recourse no what am i gonna do
yeah what
refund no one's gonna refund you i don't
even want a refund i just said to him i
was like dude
you the problem is every guy you sent
had never done it before
everything it would have been better off
if i had done it what is it
what's the resolution over there judge
judy there is no resolution
there's i mean you're an idiot it got
done
but by the way they you're not gonna
believe this i left a bunch of trash
which is another big one yeah no i mean
when i renovated my condo
um they're like we need we don't have
all the fixtures i'm like okay so they
stopped working on it
for a month and then a month later i'm
like hey
can you finish like we're almost done
i was like yeah oh you know i realized
we don't have all the um
fixtures and i lost my mind i lost my
mind i was like
you didn't have the pictures a month ago
go get the fixtures i don't care where
you find them go get them it took you a
month to get
this is handles on a on like shaker
cabinets i was very upset
well they they just they think they're
just bad liars
and they're used to people that the
people are very intimidated by
construction people
oh yeah they're like when you're like a
half a [ __ ] like i am where you're like
you've never held held a tool
uh you get you get swindled yeah you
they'll just do anything you're like
okay
sorry guys i mean i don't mind i got two
thousand dollars
funded because uh i was like i'm
out of how many oh out of a lot but they
did the work but i was just like you let
my
apartment sit there for a month for door
for for handles yeah
put on the handles you have they're
missing three and then they did so they
did no work
for the three and i it just they they
could just [ __ ] you if you're not paying
attention essentially i think they also
they saw they because i'm a single guy
i'm kind of like ah
yeah bianca moving on
did you see did you see the debates did
i
did you did you see what the only
takeaway
people got the fly i mean well that's
the whole point the
sadness of american politics is
is and i don't i'd say america because
it's the only place i've ever lived but
because i don't think people anywhere
else would be like
this is so important to pay attention to
a flight the funny thing is i've lived
outside the country i don't know if i've
mentioned it
ever on this podcast um most places
don't have a two-party system
those places have so they don't have two
on two no most people have like four
parties five parties
right system so it's not so it's more
specific
per faction um something's freaky
go ahead but it uh it does
break up the division you know
yeah so it's not just like us versus
them yeah
culturally it's really the fly
i i truly didn't even see the fly like i
called the fly i just want to say in the
previous episode i said somebody said
that oh they did somebody somewhere i
saw that
well i don't think people know you'd be
on the phone somebody eat
something um so i don't think people
remember this
if i made memes i would have made a meme
but the fly showed up
on the 2016 debates it landed on hillary
oh well i was gonna yes and no and now
i was gonna tweet or say something like
hey you know if you're gonna say
that uh like a fly landing on pence
is just so we're clear is as dumb as
when they you say like
obama smells like sulfur like who said
that
alex jones said it he smells the beast
um and it's so it's like saying
people get mad when like uh evangelical
will go
uh there's tornado because of the queers
yeah
the gay reign yeah and it's like um
that's as dumb as saying there was a
rainbow because of kobe
it's all dumb it's not it's not
no i know we've kobe and it was 8 4
40 24. do you not believe it
and then kobe came down and that was the
name of like i
it's all i if i believe in them
then billy graham or or whoever has as
much validity as
the the uh kobe people right
or like then they pass the law and i
look to my left
and what do you know as a sheep sorry
it's okay
um no well it's it's similar like
you know when it's cove you're like yeah
kobe's but then yeah
uh when i was in mexico city i went to
where the vergende guadalupe the lady
our lady virgin
and they and then i found out what the
deal was with her
it sounds a little far-fetched a
religious story
like far-fetched you mean to tell me
um it was like so you picked some roses
and then
a ver like an angel appeared on your
apron yeah it's all dumb it's
it's it's things on toast any
things oh
or just it's so it's like clouds in the
sky pitiful
it's this pit of like no no you can't
say that they're dumb and you're smart
when
when your symbolism works none of it
works
i've decreed it none of the none of the
systems work
um the other takeaway from the well no i
i was just watching it either thought
that
pence and trump are really good debaters
if you don't know anything you have to
not know anything
but man are those guys you have to just
strictly not know any information right
but pence is a [ __ ] soldier yeah
he's power and he's pious he does sound
like he works for npr and i'll tell you
what
he used he wasn't he was a radio guy for
like a decade he has a good voice
of course he does that's what i'm saying
like they're good debaters
yeah if you didn't know everything they
said was a lie
you'd be like these guys that's why i
was like it was a runaway i was like
no it wasn't it wasn't a runaway they by
the way
they they went on cnn afterward and they
ten people
who how many people who think there was
a clear winner eight people raised their
hands
how many thought it was kamala four how
many thought it was pence four
it's just everyone just everyone's just
just like no that's why i was saying was
like trump lost
he yes fine but biden didn't win
yeah and and same with come along
she what all that like i do love the
like
i'm speaking some there's a nice letter
about you for that
okay um and uh
but all the [ __ ] that liberals like like
she is the queen of side eye
and she's guys why are you
[ __ ] it's not gonna pick voters off
in western pennsylvania ohio where it's
still tied
i remember dave i was going like man
ohio was the bellwether of the country i
was like why would you brag about a
[ __ ]
state that you happen to be in you don't
like any bragging rights i don't like
i don't know bragging about
a thing that you did not
like you know our my town has the
highest rate of i
don't give a [ __ ] if you did it great
but like if it's
a cloud go [ __ ] yourself um
it's not gonna help get it's not gonna
make sassy doesn't
isn't worth 1.3 votes you just need to
persuade people
where they are which liberals can't even
fathom how someone could be conservative
yeah
they can't even i was talking dave we
talked about this on podcasts
yeah like they can't so you can't
imagine why someone
would be anti-abortion or want lower
taxes
or want to close the border you can't
imagine it the [ __ ] are you talking
about
it's not that hard to imagine no
especially if you leave your liberal
bubble
it's really i feel like people in austin
get it more
but la new york yeah
even though there's a lot of
conservative people in new york they're
not that conservative
they're also nowhere where you want to
be folks
they're yeah you don't you don't like
albany
they're they they're yes and they're not
even in manhattan they're in they're in
the bronx and queens oh yeah um but uh
but yeah they can't i was you know i had
a good
offended uh moment of indication which
is as sweet a moment as i can get
come on if you got a person like mine um
woman i know who
was a volunteer for bernie and
now she's volunteering for biden and
i said like so now that you're doing
this she's doing like you know
pla
what do you think of bernie and she's
like the more i deal with like
centrists and conservatives
bernie had no [ __ ] chance no like no
[ __ ]
but do you think he had a chance in
2016. i feel like it was
too it was like so weird i feel like a
bernie versus trump would have been
more plausible then no i think he would
have lost
the popular and i don't i think i think
it would have just lost
everything you wouldn't have won the
popular or the or the uh electoral
college the
yeah you have it's she she the my friend
known as it was like
yeah it's like a tran you're asking
people for like a transformation
yeah and it's too big a thing i told you
when i did that
when i did that um that uh
march at the oakland port authority in
the long the
like black and brown longshoremen that
were like plm
and then you know i love that guys i
know i love a joke about stereotypes
and then a trans
fluid sort of person i don't know there
were
they identified as something else than
they yes
and the longshoremen were losing on a
microphone
he was like oh right brother speak and
he was like you just assumed my agenda
and he was like i'm
sorry to the sister
for calling her a brother he had no idea
what was going on he was so
confused and i personally believe
that he will stay confused forever he's
an old black guy that worked at the
first authority
he done they don't even know what you're
talking about he really
looked at a person that had a beard and
to him look like a man like that guy
uses a computer
sometimes sometimes but he doesn't
really know what the [ __ ] is happening
he doesn't um
he doesn't believe that it went to the
pla
the email went he doesn't something
happened
so i know something happened and the
next time i talked to him
he said he had gotten that like there's
no
there's no it's like sebastian's joke
about his dad setting up the computer
and using the mouse as a foot pedal like
that's
absolutely right i i thought of another
sebastian
story while you were saying this this
story doesn't
john legend had a party eight years ago
or something
that's the whole story john legend party
eight years ago
and john sebastian's terms of john and
chrissy
and so at the end of the party it's just
me sebastian john and chrissy
and this like young black kid right and
uh
i look over at sebastian talked to the
young black kid
and it's just the five of us in their
house and sebastian goes
i mean how do you get a name like frank
ocean
oh my god how'd you even get that name
and just trying to explain the name
frank ocean
to sebastian because he wasn't frank
wasn't
had didn't have any albums out he just
was called frank ocean and
had a demo and trying to explain that's
what that guy
yeah at the port authority was going
like what frank
what do you got i mean how do you
so you're born frank ocean ocean
i mean that's what a name this guy's got
i mean when i just
look because everyone's like how dare
you in the crowd and he
when he was like i'm sorry to the sister
for calling him a brother i was like
let's just go get you're never the only
way you're gonna get that
it's it's meeting them where they are
and trying to appeal
to the the things you have in common
you're not going to shame them with side
eye
and but shouldn't we do it like
mcdonald's commercials you know
mcdonald's commercial
it's always they have a black one they
have a white one they have an asian one
depending on the markets because all the
markets are different
i feel like politics should kind of be
because we can all agree we want the
same things but we don't
want them marketed to us the same i
would yeah i was talking to a guy
i said something about this the other
day on twitter and somebody said
something about he works in
solar energy and i wrote back to him i
go you know
you would sell more panels if you were
dirty
all the time yeah like an oil person
hire all the
coal workers yes they they just think
it's it's like something americans think
that one type of energy
is homosexual and european and one is
heterosexual and american
and it's because one is dirty
yeah one is gritty and dirty and you get
you get covered in in dust and
oil and you gotta use a special soap and
one is yes
and one is just some [ __ ] on your roof
that guy installs once
right but it's because it looks
queer no other word for it
uh they won't they just they're like i
don't like that
yeah i don't trust that meanwhile there
are so many more jobs
in clean energy now than in coal or
fracking
like the the growth is all in in
renewable
but people are like nah you're going to
tell me what job i can and what's a good
job and what's and i was like
hey what you can do you'll get just as
dirty cool but that's the thing it's
like
one none of those jobs are nice jobs
durable jobs and that's the weirdest
thing it's like come on have foresight
weak especially clean energy can be
expensive so we can't actually
manufacture it in america you know
it doesn't have to be outsourced
somewhere like they can that's not even
the issue anymore the
like manufacturing is oh yeah oh yeah
i mean that's that you can invest in
this industry and you know you have like
some sort of
longevity like career longevity because
it's not really
you know it's like so specific it's like
anybody can get some coal out the
out the ground we don't need it to be on
another issue which is
the least the job that takes the least
qualifications
they expect the most stability in
that is so good but it speaks to their
their level of self-pit it's the cop
thing it's a level of self-pity
yes like well they're gonna tell me
what one of the guys said a thing that
you're gonna tell me what's a good job
and what's not a good job yeah
yes that job [ __ ] stinks buddy and i
say this from a place of decency i don't
i don't call me crazy i don't want you
to take a tiny train
a mile deep into a hole yeah i
again i know that's crazy when you could
basically just be laying tile in the
desert
yeah and it will come we'll get you
shade
here's the bad news you're not gonna get
black lung are you mad
you're not going to get black along
you're still upset i love my
my uncle got blood yeah it's just these
dumb [ __ ] loyalty
to these jobs that are [ __ ] awful
jobs
awful jobs it's weird we have this i
guess in the heartland
there's this um well my dad did it his
dad did
this lineage thing i also feel like
americans don't have a lot to hang on to
in terms of history
so for them it's like that's what my
family does
it's the conservative thing it's they're
it's in the title
they're conservative they just don't
change anything
just how things are now i feel safe i'm
fine
we're going to conserve it and
progressives want to make progress and
because everybody would like to no no no
no
no blacks i don't want a black uh
president i don't want a black vice
president i don't want to um
it's like that joke you do when you're
like no one does drugs and gets more
conservative
yeah i'm not sure you're right yeah i
was thinking of dave's joke about
um coal where he does
absolutely he's absolutely for the
uninitiated
he is doing yosemite sam to
the vocal tick right you could lay their
[ __ ] assignments things next to each
other i
noticed i go in 1993 i said if i go
you're [ __ ] bugs bunny
and he didn't even know what i was
talking about you're [ __ ] bugs bunny
he's
doing yosemite the whole warner brothers
library has implanted itself on
he then says he sells himself as bugs
bunny you i want the streets to know
that that was my opportunity it was neat
poor had a bob i didn't have a lot going
on
um you did have a bob i had a bob the
kurt kurt kob
trump is home y'all i mean trump home
these these weeks are so long
it's it's uh so much has happened
you can't you can't podcast enough guys
i we need
all these podcasts we need a [ __ ]
70 000 podcast new podcast today i'm
sure this jumps dead
uh he is
he's just such a giant [ __ ]
and again if you didn't know anything
you would go this guy is [ __ ] smart
and brave
why are we freaking out and but you have
to they're running again
their opponent is reality
that's who they're running against so
the longer they can just be like huh
the problem is some of the reality got
into their into their bubble
whatever yes i mean it's such a there's
a million metaphors about covid
i know um you know bianca no one knows
better than you about
covered metaphors come on guys it's me
classic
yeah no it's so funny it's so fun
no one wants anybody to die but
it was eerie it was eerie
it just felt like a meme came to life
and the consequences were the president
could die
it was just creepy feeling she's like
god
did he was all that all those videos for
this jesus christ
it seems so long ago i know were these
he's been cured in a week he
was that a week yeah he came home last
monday i believe
and today's monday he came home last
monday we don't know i thought he's only
had it for 10 days
he's only yes i mean that he's only
[ __ ] lie
tested he publicly acknowledged being
tested
10 days ago also everybody who had to
speak about his health
just seemed like they were being held
hostage
you guys know you guys know better than
anybody i tell you
i'd love to stand here and tell you you
guys know i'm a straight shooter you
guys know that
i'm the i'm the i have a doctorate in in
uh medicine and honesty
um they don't
he somebody said this a long time ago
and it's just so true that
he ruins everything he touches every
single person
that comes in contact with him who isn't
his family
is well first of all like a dozen of
them are in jail
just in the last four years yeah and
everyone else who
who ever lindsey graham all these he
just makes
people's [ __ ] lives worse
yeah and if you don't go to jail you're
you're greatly reduced
you're [ __ ] the reputation is
reputationally
you're you're reputationally you're
you've got
uh you've got a skull fracture
like a reputational skull fracture where
it's like yeah it's the indent
well there's going to be some sweet
photos right there and you have to
pretend like no i'm good i'm fine yeah
it looks weird but it's fine
you don't need yeah um by the way
separate side issue there's an app it's
an app called
figure one go on the app store figure
one not an ad
it's basically medical pictures
and diagnoses and it ranges from heart
to like foot injury to just
um but if you're into it so wait what is
this for to diagnose yourself or to just
medical cases just random medical cases
that
that doctors and uh nurses and people
will post
as uh as like this is interesting
oh this isn't for you to get clarity on
what's ailing you no
this is just [ __ ] rubbernecking
oh i love a good rubber neck yeah i
thought you might oh yeah cause you know
i watched monster inside me
infected see it figured out um
something's
killing me c on there okay yes
everything ever he it's a reputational
skull fracture
and and
i don't think i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna say none of them are gonna
recover but i intend
and i i intend to boo
these people in person
now now i did [ __ ] up because at the
twain prize
yeah you should have said something like
a [ __ ] troll oh i
there was a thing the next night at some
restaurant
yeah if you can believe dave had an
event yeah uh you were gone
i was gone were you there yeah i just
went oh did you go to the
university or high school but kellyanne
conway came in
and i wish i'd yell i wish i'd booed
because it's like a hot restaurant dude
she didn't come in for the party
oh okay there's so many trump aides
there at the
night i was just like this is dc is
weird yes it's almost like the politics
are
it's corrupt it's so corrupt you can't
believe it these people would
people don't have any a couple about a
dozen people have
actual um integrity and we'd go like no
i don't care if it
if i get penalized for believing this
i'm gonna do the thing that's most
politically advantageous to me
moment to moment yeah and that's you and
i think we're talking about
somebody was talking about how trump
faked
cope it's like he can't think more than
eight seconds
in in front of him i had to i'm just
starting to
realize that um
you know it it works really well at
least where we live
when trump supporters they're idiots how
could they believe
these things q and on that's ridiculous
and then
you meet friends that are like
he's faking it and i'm like no they're
what the [ __ ]
no he's not faking it like think about
it trayvon
yeah our friends smart guys why
are we losing touch with
a good sensible connection to
you know like presumed reality like of
course that's probably
not the case like what it feels like
that isn't going on in people anymore
people don't have this thing in their
head where they question
because they don't think it's a sign of
intelligence it's we talked about this
i'm realizing we talked about this last
week we talked about all the time i'm so
i'm so lost in what week it is
and what's happened but people we know
that aren't
that don't have a void for being
intellectuals or
having something over somebody trayvon
and roy
seem like sound dudes yep writer for the
daily show and
corresponding for the daily show yeah
what would make someone like them think
that
because they want to think that it's
and even by the way the [ __ ] that people
i posted the thing about us
not believing and they were like and the
things that they
proposed were like uh
mk ultra and which was
like a cia thing and iran contra
and those are those are good yeah those
and i was like these are good
yeah um but they people on the streets
didn't know about them
it's my point it was never like you know
someone so
so and so and then you go oh yeah it
turns out you're right it's just
nothing's happening the film goes oh
there's i think i was in mma
mk ultra is it gone yeah mk ultra
and it turns out it's uh this thing that
we were doing
um yeah i have so many
there's so much news that there was a
thing you know when you go when they
built
when they used to do like when they
built the brooklyn bridge yeah uh
people would get the bends yeah yeah
because they were doing also called
caissons disease what that that's what
uh i guess the guy who discovered his
cason i don't know okay but i have
k pods disease which is you just heard
you don't know what it's 2020 you're
doing a podcast weekly podcast
there's so much happening that you don't
you don't even know what the [ __ ]
happening
well you know what we're doing it was a
good one k-pods
uh yeah but donald trump is um bad
okay and uh but he home he homes
you just again they're running against
reality and every once in a while
why reality breaks through and um
i love that biden's like not doing a
debate with you
that's not exactly what happened they
just couldn't decide on
virtual trump wouldn't do it virtually
right no i mean in person
because he literally said he goes i'm
not going to
uh uh not do it virtually i'm not going
to do it virtually when they can cut me
off whenever they want
that it's like okay good also virtually
i think like what you're saying feels
more
cuck homosexual
oh it's a fake it's a it's a fruity
fruity it's it's a safe
person to person is heterosexual
rituals i'm on a camera i don't know
it's a little
newfangled something about it
seems like it has sex with other men
on um will you explain there are many
armenian genocide two
2.0 um so it's basically
so turkey and armenia we understand that
happened that was a while ago
and then 108 years ago or something
2000 like 1903 or something yeah so
in around a little bit after my
grandmother was born that's how old i am
go ahead that's so long ago 1897.
oh yeah we talked about this talk about
this yeah you got k-pods it's fine
um and then so in it's basically
azerbaijan
versus armenia and turkey is siding with
azerbaijan because of just
i think historically right culturally
they're just buds
so in the like north of azerbaijan or
south i don't remember there's a lot of
it's mostly ethnic armenians that live
there
and they're being persecuted and killed
and i think since there's just like tens
of thousands of them have
died did someone say we're gonna finish
the job did i see that somewhere
oh that's rude i feel like i saw that
finish the job who said that maybe i'm
confusing with the lakers
oh no wait don't do that
yeah right there right there
there should be by the way if you make
an app go do a thing where it's a
warning that
there's it's behind a pay wall just go
up to the top
they're trying to finish people are
distraught thinking they're trying to
finish the job
eastern uh eastern u.s central committee
on the iranian revolutionary federation
too long a title
iran um no armenian
uh yeah they're trying to finish the job
from 19.
whatever uh yeah no so it's now it's
azerbaijan
turkey versus uh
i can't you know i was i read an art
i've read a few articles the names
so many z-k no they got too many
it's hard to i think that's there's an
old joke that somebody did in the 80s
which is
iran and iraq are fighting so much
because they keep
getting each other's mail stupid
and i and i feel like this is i it's
also
really [ __ ] subtle
what's subtle as it as a american i go
armenia and azerbaijan yeah it's time
how different
ah all right guys it's like come on
yeah no for real like like remember when
bush said that the one of the
it was like he sort of said jokingly
like
that saddam hussein tried to kill his
dad yeah and everyone was like what are
you talking about
in that part of the country that's
grounds for war for 200 years
right but we're just from the is from
the west we're like
what do you do it's an old thing so 110
years ago
right what do you why why do you who
remembers it
but they it's they want acknowledgement
they've you know armenians have been
fighting for this forever
right and there's still a lot of
um there's still i think armenians in
turkey that
it's just a lot of border [ __ ] it's a
lot of
uh so it's but it's also the erdogan
proxy war
in armenia ugly echo of turkey's
genocidal campaign
so they're backed by turkey right so
it's just basically like
it's it's much like a trump scandal
there's a layer of complexity that i'm
like
that makes me as a as a reader lose
interest
honestly i'm like what come on guys
erdogan if you attack him then i'm mad
but if you pay for armenia to do it or
[ __ ] azerbaijan the only thing i know
about azerbaijan
is uh how to say it no the only thing i
know about jan
is from the formula one show they do a
formula one event there and i couldn't
believe that they were
pot they were a big enough country they
had buildings and [ __ ] there
they have real skyscrapers they have 40
story buildings
made of glass and steel not stones now
so
this is congratulations everybody
totally controversial because it's not
connected
but when i was doing
the protests which ones so i was in pan
pacific park which is where the protest
started
um accidentally that goes from
america to japan the pan pacific park
go ahead and that's where the protest
was and i got caught in it but i'm like
yeah sure protest 100
like i think it's [ __ ] up how
armenians are treated they're also all
over
there's a lot of our means in iran but
we're nice to our armenians i don't know
what's wrong with the rest of the world
so um
what i don't get is why a lot of
immigrant
communities in america are not pro-blm
they're not pro-black lives matter at
all
at the pan pacific park when i was there
and armenian guy asked me
what what is blm and i was like where
are you from he's like i'm marvinian and
i was like oh
what do you mean what is blm he's like
what does it stand for and i was like
black lives matter and he goes
i was like get away from me
and he's like black lives matter
okay and then i walked away i was
standing outside of iron
my friend comes back i'm like that that
was so [ __ ] rude but it wasn't rude
at all
he just did this and walked away well
you're pretty rude
yeah but you could feel the i mean some
old guys it's like yeah
sebastian frank ocean it's a classic
frank ocean sebastian don't under good
luck with all that you know
yeah um but when you look at the
armenian genocide and
the 2.0 version all it is is just
unjust persecution against like a larger
population with more power at least
going against a
more unprotected un
you know underrepresented population and
they're so passionate about it
even before the thing in azerbaijan
which has only been going on for the
last
few decades they've been they're they've
still talked about like
getting justice for the genocide in the
early 1900's
i don't understand why wouldn't you be
for all injustice oh
i'm sorry will let me take this because
people
are giant hypocrites and only
care about their issue and don't see any
crossover don't even know what you're
talking about
like but this was this was armenians
being slaughtered
so yeah but these are black people being
slaughtered for like 400 years
yeah but these were armenians for a
couple years
imagine if we were like well what were
the armenians wearing part of town to
live in what
what car were they driving and you know
it's not fair to link this because i
don't know how many armenians think this
that was just my one example in the same
spot where there was
the armenian protest but it felt
i don't know i can't understand why all
immigrant communities they didn't leave
their
home country because it was great no one
wants to leave their home
so why i don't i just it's frustrating
well they were being persecuted i get
them leaving but
that's fine why if you were actually if
you left
you care too much about armenians why
aren't you over there why are people
more
like why is blm more is it more
supported by
immigrants that bothers me isn't it
because they're [ __ ]
racist and they don't have black people
in armenia trudeau
they have like nigerians or kenyans
there's always like
they're always everywhere do not trust
the army do not trust the nigerians
nigerian guys come around they wear a
lot of uh they wear purple jeans
they do wear purple jeans and they have
a lot of
gold i don't think it's real um
yeah they don't they're just they'll
find it it's like in japan it's like
that
and in bank in [ __ ] bangkok thai it's
just you go to these
hong kong it's like oh and i don't know
why there's nigerians or canyons at
these places they're everywhere
kanye west you know about kanye west
have we spoken about him on the show
he's rapper
he's on my ballot he's a rapper is he i
haven't over my balance
he's a vp of someone
he's now i'm afraid that your ballot's
[ __ ] up
and now we're gonna this is gonna be a i
almost want to cut this out
why because if i don't think he's a vp
he's a vp to a
some conservative guy yeah watch
he's a vice president uh to some [ __ ]
broke down that's the guy from
from um from uh from rage against the
machine
oh dario um no it's only in california
okay uh he's a vp to this like
funnily enough neither one of them knew
they were gonna run alongside each other
in fact
kanye allegedly did not actually know or
give consent for his name oh that's cool
um all right that's uh that checks out i
didn't know
someone could accidentally because i
read that rock de la fuente has some
good songs just run the jewels
rocky wait they put his nickname rocky
del fuente first of all he sounds like
he would be the yeezy creative director
yeah he does rocky rock rocky della
fuente guerra
guerra you got me you [ __ ]
spanish-speaking [ __ ]
um what why are their nicknames spike
because it's a fun election who's jeremy
cohen
yes jewish people showing uh joe
jorgensen
and that's joe jorgensen this is joe
jorgensen
um i don't uh he kanye released a video
today
for his yeah play it because i think i
don't think he'd be fragged
what is america's destiny what is best
for our nation
our people what is just it's the
um together as a people
to contemplate our future to live up to
our dream
we must have vision we as a people he
brought will revive music videos
commitment to faith
production
faith can be restored we as a people
first of all
pause it that looked like freddy gibbs
the rapper like freddie gibbs
hey look like kanye's reading which
is like that's my favorite dog that's
the guy
that's pretty good i don't think that's
actually him no it's not wait he looks
like freddie good it looks like freddie
gibbs and michael
michael yeah michael what the michael
never be cut one
outfit um kanye's got
her put your [ __ ] music under it you
ding dong
terrible you have the [ __ ] best music
in the world
put it underneath and of course
yes someone pointed out that that looks
like a death star wait so what is he
saying
he's basically saying we're gonna we're
gonna bring america back
americans and but he's also reading
which is like dog
don't read with the show or before
memorizing doing the right
or doing the right thing one of your
classical brands stronger country
the rant would get more attraction than
this
for a little bit and then and then um
you should not i'm neil brennan and i
don't approve this message
written in wrote write in should have
had his own music
and um should have just rant should have
gone off the dome
and i bet jay-z's like why are you using
the watch the throne black and white
flag
um and uh and also
don't run for president and b
drop the easy gap whine
um give me shirts give me
uniform level shirts i know it reminds
me of remember those
i think this is a bad version of and i'm
a mormon
remember those there's a campaign on
youtube too
they were trying to give mormonism a
better name so they showed like black
peop
i've never met a shitty mormon yeah even
though they didn't allow black people
until the 80s i said what i said
no i that's what i'm saying like it was
78 that black people whatever
it's like a few years after the rest of
america it's a few years after they
they let black people vote safely really
13 years later not far later but yeah
and i'm a mormon
they were way more engaging videos that
was and ironically they used kanye's
music underneath
on the mormon video um so
kanye stop it connie you're the greatest
but please stop it please stop just
make clothes and music and maybe a co
remember when he was
making houses aren't we telling him
that's actually one of his houses in
that space shot that was one of his
kanye houses the the space
things that he had the homeless people
in out in
aren't we telling him to shut up and
dribble though kind of
no i already let him [ __ ] make
clothes
like how many things are you i don't
right uh
anyone can run for anything just you
can't be
bipolar that's my only caveat
untreated or straight up no untreated
uh i'd love for a treated person not
treated by politics
um yeah like yeah
that's it's not a majority it's he's he
doesn't understand politics
yeah he's just famous that's that's his
whole platform
so yes there have to sorry there have to
be qualifications
for um for for uh for
jobs i'm sorry there just have to be i
know it's
me i know it's mean and rude and
and um divisive and reductive but you
gotta
you gotta know how to do what job you're
trying to get
now speaking of jobs we're trying to get
oh well columbus today's
columbus day right it's indigenous
day why are we celebrating columbus
it's in digilumbus day right
um it's in digital on this day which we
should call for a decade just to ease
people into it
yeah um i don't i'm here's
i don't know if i've spoken about this
on the on the award winning
uh podcast podcast
um i don't
i'm for turning on everybody
yeah but columbus
listen to me okay sorry somebody had to
like we're all we're all you no no
somebody had to
a west some in order for this country to
be
um somebody had to
explore and find it whether you want to
go with amerigo vespucci or whoever
really did it or whatever somebody we're
all
wearing fur coats going like that was
[ __ ] up that
that columbus robbed that bank it's like
you're [ __ ] living in the country
dude
so how you don't seem that upset
that about this guy who who
who stole land and then you in
in in response to him stealing that you
gave the
the victims casinos and a few
reservations
i'm not saying i'm for columbus i'm just
saying i'm against
hypocrisy no i'm just saying like you're
against columbus are you
even the people if native americans are
against them
all day [ __ ] all day but white people
shouldn't be
any any puerto rican anybody who came
here goddamn puerto ricans
if if native americans want to be
against them
all day like i said black people
all day anyone who wasn't robbed or
kidnapped
to be in america needs to shush it
because you're living off of his
crime you're you're literally
getting the getting the [ __ ]
you're you're getting the feet you're
getting at the vig as they call it so
anyone who wasn't kidnapped
or heather genocided or anything
to be in this country they should be
thankful i don't no no i'm not saying
thankful
i'm just saying don't be how i see your
hypocrisy
well how what if they agree that it's
[ __ ] up it's not what are they doing
about it
well just because you weren't enslaved
or
killed your people weren't in slavery
killed doesn't mean you can't be
like understand that it's [ __ ] up i
agree but i'm saying
i don't think honor the guy no i know
i'm just saying like
i'm gonna fight for every one of those
statues uh no i'm just saying like
just acknowledge what a [ __ ]
hypocrite you are that you're doing
exactly nothing yeah to help native
american people
or indigenous indigenous people and
fighting for it to be renamed indigenous
people as
indigenous people are getting [ __ ]
reamed by covid and [ __ ]
decimated by alcoholism and drug
addiction
you don't like uh you don't like a
consolation prize i don't like
the appearance of
i don't like surface things that's the
thing with the statues like i don't want
it
the the i want to get to the nougat of
justice and the negative justice
is not uh uh
indigo lumbus or columbu indigenous
day um it's it's
[ __ ] i mean it's impossible without a
time machine because
the reason native americans have such
bad drug and alcohol addiction is
because
their answers got decimated so there's
no
no solution but calling in indigenous
people's day
is as close to nothing as you can do and
still not change anything
yeah it's [ __ ] yeah it's just like
it's yours you know what we're gonna do
we got your
cake honey yeah no we'll bring it to the
reservation that you live on you know
that shitty
where no one wants to live ever yes you
know that shitty
basically a public park
that you live in this is your park girl
good luck getting like
water and electricity yeah um so i went
to a when i was at the pan pacific park
trying to uh fight a bunch of armenians
to get
to a frank ocean
i i marched a little with them but
going somewhere uh there was a
comedy show and there was actually there
was a funny
this guy had a funny bit his name is rob
hayes he's a comic black dude
he's funny and he was saying how he's
like the confederacy was only around for
five years
and the migos have been around for seven
so i don't know why we don't have that
and
when you put it like that it's like yeah
oh that's weird we really have only had
the confederacy wasn't
this long-standing american you know
established things it also wasn't even a
thing it wasn't
it was the thing but like it's like
the crips are a better way
like they were like we're not this we're
that like no you're still
this and we're gonna kill you until you
say we're still that
yeah and so you say we're we are we are
part of america
yeah it's true it's not it's not a real
thing to get but it was just uh
they tried to move out of their parents
house by going on the roof
and it's like no [ __ ] get back in
your room
you still live in this house no i don't
it's a
it's a um rupees mine
uh yeah so that's my thing with columbus
now speaking of which
speaking of hypocrisy
[Music]
our friend uh bill burr got in fake
trouble
he got a fake shovel for his sunrise
live monologue in which he
what i missed uh so bill
talked about white women in less than
flattering terms and by that he means
what do you think he just said how did
you hijack the woke movement
true just like they hijacked the metoo
movement right that's literally i was
hoping he'd say
uh yes black men are being murdered
indiscriminately but a comedian texted
me 10 years ago
i was hoping for that punchline didn't
show up did he
i didn't know he didn't i didn't pitch
it to him and he didn't uh
uh if you pitch burr a bit it's
guaranteed he'll never do it
oh he's like guaranteed
uh so he went after white women by
saying
it's basically the same point dave made
which is white women
getting upset and it's my
the thing i'm saying about columbus is
dave's joke was
you you were in on the heist you just
don't like your
your cut you're [ __ ] white women
did just as much bad as bla as
as white men what was that they
they when he got home they [ __ ] him
yeah so
just they're the they just they turned
and they're the witness for the
prosecution
yes they're just like yeah so now
they're like i didn't know i didn't want
to
can i get a plea deal yeah you're
absolutely right so
um a friend of the
show who i think will come on this one
of these weeks
yay executive produce silent executive
producer who's never even heard the show
uh always says the in a slave uprising
the the first person they kill is the
wife
first person that killed yeah i can't
prove it
i think he probably has two examples but
like that's how it goes
it's like so this thing of like i didn't
lady
you [ __ ] live in the big house
yeah what'd you think was good yeah like
bird did a version on his other special
which is like you're in the jacuzzi with
us
right um so that's how we and then what
happened
they were just upset that how
dare he go out it's like he's proving
your point
we have problems too not really
not compared to everyone else what's
your joke
white women are coming in second place
in a race
in a 500 race they're mad that they're
in second like what
this is rigged ah lady you're on the
stand but it's
really [ __ ] it's right it's
relatively not rigged for you
but are you is it as fair to you as it
is to white men
no but not by much it's not
not by much not when we talk about all
the other riggings
that are going on yes and then yes in a
white woman
you're getting shouldered out of
by your husband like an opportunity yeah
have it by your husband
by a guy your brother your dad your
husband whoever
like it's it stays in the fa in the
white family
is my point uh so but burr got
in fake trouble there was a twitter he
got there was twitter keval speed and
twitter gravel
no your friend no i got into twitter
karate correct
um i sent it to you i thought
[Music]
the one about it didn't seem like a long
thing though it was stupid
i said kellyanne conway's daughter oh
who's 15.
was a curfew should have a only
fans for white house intelligence
okay in retrospect should have said
patreon or
no if i say patreon it's not a joke okay
but what about
is there a way no there i trust me i did
the calculation i'm a comedy writer
i went through all that i know i'm just
i went through
all of the possibilities and only fans
is the funniest one it's the newest one
it's the jokey one it's it's tick-tock
to instagram if i'm gonna make a joke
i'll be like what are you [ __ ]
tick-tock over here
that's the joke if i go instagram over
here it's a eight-year-old app
only fans and i did look up doesn't just
have porn so i knew i was covered
right what do they have feet uh no it's
it truly was for fans of like hey
everybody
it's your boy like it's it was like a
cameo
monthly campaign thing yes uh and
and then and then it's all sexy then
they tried
yeah they everybody tried to [ __ ]
attack me and
the whole thing and the people were like
this is wrong
and uh how many how many people did you
lose
it gained 300 people hilarious so the
act
coming back from parasites the fact the
idea that these people know about
right and wrong and comedy and then a
comedy writer
dm me and he was on some like so you
really can't say i'm like
you know you could if you wanted to turn
this into
because it actually apparently did turn
into a q and on thing the thing that
people don't realize is wait what
you can just mute these people you just
wait they were like
they tied me to q and on i think
oh like now you're i think i don't know
i know he doesn't even eat pizza y'all
y'all
i don't i mean i don't think comet pizza
has vegan pizza although it
who knows um and
so but i just muted it and then people
it was like you just i don't see any of
it
and uh and but people come it was just
so embarrassing and
people it's people lecturing me about
what's good comedy and what's right
what's wrong and it's like
you don't know what you are taught it's
exactly what i said last week which is
i'm an expert on this [ __ ]
like you were here when
seth called yep about about sketches and
i don't know if you could hear the
conversation
someone who doesn't understand sketches
wouldn't even know what we're talking
about
like just like the level of this person
that yeah it was actually really
nice to hear two very like
prolific comedy people talk about
particular sketches yeah and even though
i could totally keep up it was just nice
to see you two talking about it it was
me and sad meyers talking about sketches
from sorry live appraising the sketches
and going like i'd be like no i like
this but i didn't like that
and i was like cool because we can parse
it out
right it's the thing i said about
listening to carmelo anthony talk about
basketball and
on jj reddick's podcast you
you truly go i don't know what i'm
talking about i have no idea what i'm
saying
yes yes the thing is
let's take you guys as an example
nobody's
riding any one office that was a bad
sketch
it was like i didn't like that that part
was good when he did this
one line that was very good this didn't
work and x y z blah blah blah so
people aren't really listening they hear
one thing yes it makes them feel
i didn't like that and then we wipe the
whole thing
clean bad there's no value in what
you're saying
right it's the difference between when
people go that's not
funny or that's wrong the wrongs
the wrong thing to read on twitter would
have been
uh claudi whatever claudia conway i
think her name is
should have an only fans that's the
child pornography version
and whatever only just the same tweet
just without
the punchline which is for white house
intel
so i know what the gross illegal version
is
i have no interest in doing it because i
don't believe it and it's gross and not
funny and
and like exploitive and all this [ __ ]
okay but as a comedy person
you know as a writer and
and stand up you know that you know
sometimes you know better than the
audience and you know that some jokes
even though it's a good joke and i know
this about you if it doesn't work two or
three times
you don't [ __ ] do it because it
doesn't land so
it doesn't mean it's not a great joke
but if you hear
a daughter that's underage and only fans
and people make an association and don't
like it
what's the difference between you saying
that at the store and no one laughing
you're not going to do it again maybe
you'll do one more time and then guess
what i'm not going to tweet that again
either
no but then what why not just be like oh
that one didn't work why because
yeah it is no because it did work there
were
20 comedy writers that liked it yeah
there were 2 000 retweets
there was yeah there were 2000 retweets
there was like it had get
big numbers across the board a lot of
comments a lot of retweets a lot of
likes
so you didn't like it but they think if
they don't like it
it's not funny or it's wrong
and it's like you're saying there has to
be some sort of justice you're saying
that
you're basically i'm a cook or a chef
and i'm you're saying
not only do i not like this dish it is
food poisoning and i'm telling you it's
not food poisoning it's too spicy for
you and not to your palate
but you're not you don't know what
you're talking and that's what
the fight became about that for me which
is you don't know what you're talking
about and people
hate when you say that people think it's
arrogant and so
i've been a comedy writer for 25 years i
know a bunch of [ __ ] about it yeah
and i understand the levers and even now
i feel
immodest but i'm i i'll be modest unless
someone goes
you don't lie like shut the [ __ ] up you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
i had a living metaphor come to life
which was i was
it was ice cream day last week and i'm
in line
and people behind me were saying stuff
about ice cream
that was so dumb wow neil somebody at
one point
no i didn't and someone at one point
goes vanilla is awesome that's how
like just the dumbest just first of all
that's not vanilla is awesome no it
isn't it's the building block
of ice cream civilization without
vanilla
we got nothing okay and you can
i way rather eat plain vanilla than
plain chocolate that's my
but that's my palette yours is not food
poisoning it's a disagreement yeah
but i they were so basic and dumb
that i just thought well this is the
people i'm arguing with
on twitter and they're just but they're
just they just got low iqs
so why am i wasting my time the only
people i did waste my time on is saying
like
no i'm an astronaut and you're telling
me about space
and you don't know what you're talking
about but people resent it
so much that you say no i'm an expert on
a thing that you think you're an expert
on but you're not
right but then is when you when you
think about it isn't
comedy truly subjective no
you think there are these these just
like
fountains everyone's got the same top 20
comedians
it's like it's subjective in the but
you're not going to tell me
um that it's like no everybody's kind of
[ __ ]
prior dave chris joan rivers
well how many times do you make a bad
joke
so you don't think any of you i don't
think i ever have no i'll
i accept a bad joke it's just i'm just
trying to go through it
no it's just a dud i know a bad joke i
know like the
where the cl where the weight of it like
i know a bad joke is like that wasn't a
bad joke i
there's jokes that i've made that are
just like but they're not
immoral you know what i mean it's like
that joke i made on here about
the gymnastics girls
being it'd be like michael jordan one
six championships and
phil jackson stuck his finger to the
spot did anybody have problem with him
no okay because i asked michaela maroney
about it beforehand but it was a dud i
tried it on stage
four times dud yeah you know what it
needs more explanation because when you
explain to me more i'm like oh yeah
i know but it's because we don't but
it's also because we don't
that one doesn't work because at least
for an audience member because
we don't think of we don't think of how
hard it doesn't work because we can't
even fathom how [ __ ] up it is
they that they just won championships
and we're getting molested
i mean i've had the [ __ ] that like
people
like that the level of comedy
i one time pitched a joke to chris
uh to chris rock and he goes three too
many words
like you don't know like you just don't
like yeah no one can do that yeah no
[ __ ] nobody can do that
but there are certain people that like
just the level of understanding is like
very high level of understanding so when
people start telling me you know
it's like buddy and then somebody else
said like oh so you're saying
uh you're saying that comedians are uh
on the same plane as rocket scientists
and i wrote
somebody ago no no there's way more
rocket scientists than great comedians
there's like thousands of rocket
scientists
in the world there's probably 30 000
rocket scientists i don't even know what
that means but
probably 30 000 and in the world again
the thing that people don't like to
think about
140 great comedians there's not 30 000
of them
that's what i'm saying like but like
[ __ ] you right
i know buddy but isn't who so who had
that joke
i hate quoting and not knowing but there
was they were talking about how
on youtube beethoven yeah that was mine
that was yours yeah
i've been fighting the same by the way
it's the clip in that which we should
get to the comedy store documentary
where i said
i play this game online let's get to it
let's
well let's get to it
[Music]
that's so funny uh very funny um
the comedy store documentary did you
watch
uh you know when it's a place you've
worked out for so long and it's
it's like schlep work i'm not there
phillip fulfilling my dreams
you wouldn't know it by the way how good
you are had it go ahead he's done
i'm very good at it i know um
i also never signed any anything to say
like
you could film me i don't know i know
there's some
like wait i should see you good will you
let me know if you do
there are some waitress waiter moments
in the back and they always had a camera
and i was just like [ __ ] off like i
don't want to be in this thing
um because that would be the biggest
thing i've ever done
is be a background waitress you may know
her
from that one scene um how'd you like it
i i liked binder mike binder the
director
was sent has been involving me
in the edit a little bit bijan edited an
episode
so i was i've got to yell at binder
every few weeks it must be
good whiz was great it was perfect uh
for me
um so we got the yellow binder and
so i but i've watched i probably watched
it four times this week
i just like i wait how many episodes are
there there's only one this week i watch
the same one
no there's two now now yeah as of last
night yeah oh okay uh but i watched and
you were watching and i watched the same
why because i like
if i like something i like it
so yeah yeah i like it a lot i think
it's great but it but
it also like came along it like i was
able to
not like it was me who did it but i'm
saying like i was
able to say hey you need to show
how big jimmy walker was and then he
he did some he would like address some
of the things i said so it's
i have to watch it multiple times as a
show of gratitude
as show respect like no i'm i that was
my
yeah but and not even in a just like i i
don't i
i like that's not why i like it i like
it because i
i like the world i still
don't think in a weird way that
it captures culturally how i
the clip he used to me was me saying
there's not a building in america that's
had a bigger
um impact on culture which you go
that couldn't be true and then you think
about it go name a building
yeah a building a building and i'm not
talking about like the white house or
congress or whatever
i'm talking about a pop culture a
building it's 30 rock is the only
one that you could say just because
snl uh fallon seth yeah
of course they shot rosie o'donnell's
talk show there huge
um you could say that but but
it's also a weird thing and it's almost
too big to
cover it's a
it's a one room
two rooms where richard pryor
and uh
anthony jesselnick both
blossomed or richard pryor and sebastian
or richard pryor
and joe rogan or richard pryor and eliza
or whitney or
whoever yeah um
that's never it's not like ah the
troubadour is like that
yeah troubadour had one kind of music
pryor is basically like hip-hop or if
you want to include
rock or dave or um
whoever else like the p if you just go
they do hip-hop comment or
def comedy jam that was like the center
of deaf comedy jam
um like i went there when they were do
like
i saw tupac there yeah so everybody
talks like the old waitress would be
like tupac was a great tipper
yeah like he was there a lot yeah so
that's the part that you kind of
can't it's not like oh it's like the
lakers
no because everyone [ __ ] up
two rooms and what's three but
right but belly i don't count the belly
room because it's they're not doing real
[ __ ] it's all bringers up there
i know but i'm saying it's two rooms
that
and the room has an influence on
had an influence on pryor and
jim carrey and jay leno and david
letterman
and whoop whoopi goldberg developed her
show
in the belly room yeah but what that's
the one woman show yeah
which i didn't know that wow that's cool
yeah like were you like whoa and she's
whoopi says there's a thing that like
ties us all to she's like people around
the world
that are regulars that did time at the
store and
to the earlier point about rocket
scientists probably
350 paid regulars which when you think
about it you're like
that's it 100 probably dead
man okay 500 that's not a lot yeah it's
not a lot
oh yeah the the with all the when you
see the the photos on the wall i'm like
a lot of broken dreams like a lot of
that we're not going to focus on that oh
sorry yeah i don't know
i know i was like well i think they're
all a lot of them are dead but no it's
true there's not that many
yes there's so it's a it's a it's rare a
fighter it's whatever you want to talk
about but it's also
so pryor develops live in the sunset
strip there or
live in concert there and letterman
develops
how to m's how to be a host and
robin develops his voice whoopi develops
her voice
and then and then now and then also now
so there's not
there's not a music venue that had
uh otis redding and maroon five
right developed development that's the
thing it's like these are not
famous people right and it's almost too
big a concept
to cover yeah because i tried to
like i binder used me talking about and
it's still
i still didn't later on i was like [ __ ]
i should have mentioned this person
right in living color i should have
mentioned um
martin lawrence that was martin's home
club yeah he still comes
yeah but i'm saying like he got his
hbo half hour deal at the store
yeah they would say i i when mitzi's uh
when during mitzi's funeral it was
really
interesting to hear all these people
come up and talk and they were like
you could kill in the main room on a
friday you'd be on
i don't know johnny carson yeah i mean
that's the that they cover that they
cover
they do that you get carson but that's
one show in one period that's like
yeah okay i'm talking about the length
of it
i'm just saying that's the creepy that's
like the it's not even creepy it's
it's a big concept for
it's like where they say one person's a
story and 10 000 people as a statistic
that's almost the in terms of like how
they sold the famine in ethiopia that
was like the observation like we can't
just show everybody we just have to like
one starving child at the store
there's so many people that
like you can't it's like too
it's so crazy yeah it's weird one time
we were talking to somebody
and they're like oh yeah like one of the
old old waitresses
uh maybe eleanor she was like jim carrey
was just a door guy
and he married a waitress yeah and i was
like
looked at all the door guys i'm like no
i know god but it wasn't anything there
wasn't
some extra magic behind it no it was the
same thing we're doing
the same it's the dynamic at the store
the nice thing is
it feels like it has not changed that
that's tons of comics sitting around
it's really the one place
i love and it feels so old school where
you really just have conversations
everyone has yeah that's how you pass
the time yeah of course people do 15 20
minutes whatever
right and we're schlepping drinks and
people have actual jobs
but everybody everybody whether you're
working or you're just there to
shoot the [ __ ] or hanging out so you
could maybe become a dork at some point
everyone's just sitting and having
conversations
and that like type of symposium
it's so encouraged there and that
exchanging of just
i don't know it's not you don't really
see that anywhere else it's also
the thing that is very hard to cover in
a documentary
they actually jimmy walker talks about
it so jimmy walker needed writers
he he just he just probably he just
wasn't a good joke writer
so he ha and his writers at one point
were
letterman leno wow and byron allen
oh my god okay so that's 500 million
500 million and a billion dollars
literally
and i was saying a binary dude he owns
the weather channel now he did stand up
once
at 17 got a job
and now ha so it's not it's
the and vladimir made the analogy it's
like triple a baseball and then if you
then
it's like that's not quite it either
because
those guys letterman had tom driessen
george miller and uh jimmy walker on his
show like twice a year
you know when he had like in the 2000s
right like when they weren't
hot and they weren't hot at all no one
else wanted him he was like
the thing that i i that's very hard to
cover which is the friendship which is
jimmy walker hiring these guys and he
they cut to a clip of him saying i'm at
the
job-getting um plateau of my career
where i can get people jobs
and the difficult
the tension that develops there because
letterman used to get leno jobs on
letterman he would have leno on the show
all the time and would let him [ __ ]
not let him murder he would [ __ ]
murder it was a launching pad
to then get to tonight's show and that's
the [ __ ] that's
really that's like to me the tension
of a place like this because it's like
triple a baseball
except that the guy that you play with
can become the head of the league in two
years right
so it's it's not even a calculation i
don't think but it's
it is really emotional it's really
emotional and
everyone is so in the same industry and
it's such a small industry that like
you don't know who's gonna be
it is really clicky too i'm surprised it
isn't more
there isn't more understanding of i feel
like comics are generally cool with each
other yeah but
behind the scenes talk a lot of [ __ ]
yeah you just have to accept that i mean
it's not in the doc
but it was in the book i'm dying up here
and i actually did a part of the doc
with lena where i interviewed lena
and so there's a the portion of the
show where of the doc where they're
watching people on the tonight show like
everyone would watch everybody right
yeah
that's what i'm talking about like this
sweet thing
and leno had a leno had one of the first
vcrs that he said was like the size of a
microwave
and like you'd have to like pull the
puck and he would go hey you want to go
watch someone so bomb
like there was that part of it where it
is very support i don't think jay's
[ __ ] cutthroat or anything it's just
naturally the only thing i want to see
someone do more than kill a [ __ ] bomb
it's [ __ ] the fun part like i know
all the [ __ ] people are going to talk
about all the people whose clicks i'm
not in i was like i know what they're
going to say
if you have at it knock yourself out um
but the emotional the
maybe the things i'm talking about are
too big for a documentary yeah no it's
hard to really cap like for example when
johnny witherspoon died
uh jd yeah like johnny le people in the
middle
has called him john but letterman and
those guys call him johnny and
everyone called prior richie yeah and
it's like this
this just this friendship it's hard to
capture
how sweet and yes deep
running this fresh friendship goes these
friendship go but
at the same time some are like obsolete
just like
dead like yeah i used to know him so
it's weird to know
where people lie you know some can have
these friendships that
are long-lasting and then some could
make it big and just like
shandling another guy that's just like
yeah i can't believe it
yeah bass i for he's just hasn't been in
it yet
is he he's gonna be though right i think
so i can't remember i'm assuming
these guys it's again it's not like the
blue note it's not the
because they can help you help the per
you help the person below you
because you don't think they're below
you yeah
they're you're you're you're 9 15 i'm a
9 30.
like i'm [ __ ] it's not showbiz may go
you know so-and-so's way beyond you and
you're like you
you don't know what you're talking about
so you think so-and-so is better than me
but they're not and i'll it's like what
dave did with me it's like people go
like what and then he's like no i'm
telling you
well that's the thing the nice thing i
think about comics and the
and comedy and the at least the vibe at
comedy clubs is a comic will see someone
be really [ __ ] talented
and be like he's talented it's not like
acting where
well i'm the one booking it i don't it
doesn't really matter that you're a
better actor than me go to a [ __ ]
acting school and be the man yeah it
doesn't matter
i'm booking i have something some je ne
sais quoi
yes that i'm booking above you and i'm
i'm more successful
by those like criteria whereas a comic
if they see someone funny
that person is funny to them forever and
they are always betting when you're
gonna pop
that's the funny thing about the doc is
that is the amount of
remember that joke you used to do yeah
michael keaton
by the way which people didn't know was
a comic i know that i knew that i always
forget
he has michael heaton has a bazooka joe
joke
that is so [ __ ] great no they just
cut to it oh cool
the saggett sets it up um and
it's so great you can't
by the way there might be a clip of this
podcast in a later episode just so you
know so i hope you did sign something
no i'm fine but sagitt
sets up uh uh keaton
and keaton remembers binders jokes and
binder remembers letterman's jokes
and that's the thing of like
we're all kind of like slaves in the
hall of the ship
and then we're like oh oh that guy was a
good rower
and then he goes hey i'm come up to the
next deck
right and then you're in the deck and a
lot of times it's them vouching for you
yeah which is i don't know if it's it's
just hard to
i didn't even think about it till i was
watching like the fourth time but what
what is the thing that's hard to what
it's hard to capture that it's hard to
capture it's really hard to capture
it's hard to capture because i think
binder probably felt like the letterman
leno thing was so
done to death yeah they did they
concentrate on the drama of it all no
they didn't even cover the talk show are
they
cool i don't know i don't
does it matter i think at this point
they're probably
it's not like a cold war it's just
nothing yeah it's like i don't think
they talk but i don't think they're mad
i didn't know that they were such good
friends i didn't know they were
they they're my binder does cut back and
forth
from letterman saying like
i don't ever i don't think i ever saw
jay bomb
to leno going like i used to watch
leonard and be like your jokes are so
[ __ ] good
and it's really sweet there's [ __ ] like
that that's really really nice yeah
um but yeah no there is something nice
about in the comedy world where you just
as long as you give credit or be like
[ __ ] who said this but
i love the quoting we do it sometimes on
here but like
we've done like five times this episode
but i just like that part of it just
feels
like such camaraderie yeah and there's
the camaraderie that you
can't you can't really it is partially
it's like you're
you're both in a beauty pageant
but you're also both rowing in a slave
ship so it's like it's
it's a bunch of different things you do
appreciate it's but at the same time
it's a little competition but not it's
never direct it's never there's never a
contest it's never direct but there is
competition
it's just on this really specific level
because i've been around actors who
it's so blatant and weird sometimes
and writers are pretty cool they don't
seem competitive with anyone
they're like ah hopefully it gets picked
up you know whereas comedians have
you captured the writing spirit pretty
nicely there
i went to a comedy i went to i went to
another if i could have one slice of
[ __ ] please what's that joke the polish
girl comes
yeah [ __ ] it right um
okay so neil star seal of approval yeah
it's great watch it's
showtime hulu whatever whoever hey life
on our planet is that a nature doc
yeah it's richard right well because
it's there's a whole
my keith might bargain okay just be
warned
thank you there's a whole thing with um
with uh how the name how we're [ __ ]
the planet
so because i don't
care about the lizards this is a this is
an omnibus
okay big this is uh richard
david attenborough david attenborough
his
wife as a nature person and what he's
seen
he's like like the first time he went to
[Music]
myanmar it wasn't myanmar but it was
burma yeah burma
it might not have been burma but uh it
might have been burma um
very different things i know they're the
exact literally the same country
you don't understand um but the way he
went
when he went how much force there was
versus how much there is now
just percentage wow also the earth what
it was in
55 what it is now in terms of overall
forest land
it used to be 63 now it's like low 40s
which sounds like ah it's not good that
was great
yeah the life on the planet was great
it's on netflix
and there was a dock that i watched on
amazon called feels good man
which is based on the guy who drew pepe
the frog
oh and how he just got [ __ ] yeah the
comic that it was based on pepe the frog
was
part of a comic book
called i think boys club and
the title feels good man is was just
from a strip
a panel of uh boys club where a guy's
taking a leak but he's got his pants all
the way down
his butt's out and he's someone goes do
you pee with your
pants down he goes feels good man which
is so funny
it's so funny to me um and uh
and and so it's cool that the guy
basically
got it became like a right wing thing
he sued alex jones made two million
dollars
and then protesters and i won't give it
away but it's [ __ ] yeah
it's a good documentary okay so watch
that there's one that i want to watch
i think it's out on sunday have you
heard about it it's called time
the yes i try to look for it no it's not
on
18th and it's about it kind of just
shows the impact of like
incarceration on black people but it's
over like 20 years
or something yeah so it's it's basically
seven up for black people in prison
yeah these guys are in a 60 year prison
sins
but anyways that's coming out and i
heard that one was really good so i'm
sure
yeah i heard it was great too and then
there's two trump ones coming out
there's one about
covid that alex gibney directed that's
been
ongoing apparently like in secret um
and then there's another one called
maybe under control or someone don't
remember i want to see the one about
somebody befriends an octopus i started
it but i didn't finish it did you hear
about that one
um yes thank you for bringing that up
my octopus teacher my octopus teacher
couldn't stand the guy
why and please i love the octopus
the guy is unbearable wait
he's like if a guy from nexium yeah was
a dj
take off your clothes he sounds like
mark ronson that's how mark honson talks
no really exactly like mark ronson yeah
it's enough one thank you
uh i think how much do you want to show
this well you got
wills invested we'll produce them uh
yeah it was like it's like a guy from
nexium got a dj career
okay
of course it's about him a lot why and
of course and i stopped watching it
because the guy made me crazy and then
someone dm
me and said and confirmed exactly what i
thought it was going to be
he became a better father as a result
and i was like i see this yeah
and shoehorn this [ __ ] sun in at the
beginning
he's like i lived by the ocean also i
have a son
and then just cut to him and it's like i
see where this is going
it was why i the thing i like about
documentaries is i don't know what's
going to happen they were so
yeah that i figured it out
well let's uh do something hit it l s
t m h
[Music]
hey naom banks i've been trying to catch
up on the show and just listened to the
spatula episode today trying to address
neil's interrupting a bianca
after watching last night's vp debate i
think the solution is clear banks simply
hit neal with a calm cool i'm speaking
kamala style i'm speaking
neil brennan i'm mr president mr vice
president mr vice president i'm speaking
and then she tried to like
like double down like lady you know what
that is
that's like when you ever hear people
they want to record their significant
other in a fight
they don't want them to know that's
funny and it's like she wanted to sound
like
i just i'm trying to go to bed stop it
why are you doing that don't turn your
back on me it's like a bad radio play
why are you putting your socks on why
are you doing a thing that people
wouldn't be able to hear until i
said it uh it was it was
the thing i had a better line for them
which is
uh mr trump mr prince
you've you've been speaking with your
actions for four years
now let's let someone else speak against
[ __ ]
z you did it you did it you tried you
tried to speak
we saw we saw what you wanted to say
and it was bad but let's be honest
they're so like they're it's like open
season for
zings getting them but they're not even
good jokes it's just
they aren't taking they aren't even
going for it they're like
i'm missing i know well that would have
been pithy and worthwhile
we have they said that for sure i
forwarded it to some people
but i don't think it's going to get it i
don't think there's going to be another
no i think we're done with the debates
um and i had another line
i can't i have to marshmallow test it um
that uh mr trump
uh thinks he built the economy when in
truth
like most things in his life he
inherited it
i think she said something similar not
that pithy
she didn't well annie you said someone
should say
everything he touches he destroys but
she said that yeah they've said that
that's not there's a there's a pot
there's a website called minus touch
goodbye um that's like spelled wrong
because you get it my toss you've got a
beal and ninky
all right lscner thank you for
all you do and say i hope you can help
me with this burning
query i have a beloved female friend
that i'm super close to talk weekly
travel together all the things however
she can sometimes be a real brat
it's always her way or the highway our
friends and i are constantly
compromising
the uh gander just to avoid an argument
for example constantly going to
vegetarian restaurants so we'll have
enough choices despite
a gang of omnivores that's the least
what a [ __ ]
um her behavior has grown so spoiled
over the last couple of years that i
decided to have a come to jesus moment
with her
uh to address my ire this was roughly in
march this year
but before i had my opportunity 2020 hit
the fan
uh i quickly turned into pretty much a
full-time protester
and she and i found common ground in our
passion for supporting the cause
i let it go as i let it go as there are
bigger pieces
of [ __ ] to fry at the moment
unfortunately her narcissism seeped into
this too
into activism you're kidding she is
constantly asking me to take her side
against our white friends she's a mixed
race
uh most of whom she's alienated because
they've not shown enough
outrage over race inequality on the so
on social media
she regularly refers to it as her
movement
the last straw was when i invited her to
do a blm march i was really excited
about
but she wanted to get drinks instead
then accuse me of not supporting black
women
because i wanted to use my extremely
limited personal time to support the
cause instead of doing something quote
fun with her
um my question for you guys is this is
de brat weaponizing
her selfishness with her black blackness
as a white it's not my place to make any
assumptions about
a pocs experience however it feels like
the moment
the movement is being used as a tool
manipulation here
uh on and on yes uh
is it impossible to tackle this with her
without inspiring racial hostility
it is impossible you're not going
you're going to win this jesus she seems
impossible
she seems like she's using it for her
gain
yeah which she seems that's the trap
yeah that's the trap of all these things
is making it so that you're not
thinking about you but the thing about
human life
is there's one camera angle
and it's our point of view and we kind
of see everything
from i'm the star of every scene and you
think you're the star of every scene and
well thinks he's the star of every scene
so of course we think that yeah
i i don't know this this person just
seems like an
[ __ ] yeah but that it's hard when
it's hard to deal with black [ __ ]
right now
blas black [ __ ] are winning yeah no
well they're
they're it's hard to deal with black
[ __ ] right now because
you can't tell them they're an [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying they are we're
we're letting them be brats yes in the
name
of well haven't we brat for
hundreds of years so that's fine i think
the problem is though
yeah she's using a lot of weird
annoy like i'm vegetarian vegan place
so although the thing is when you have a
letter like this
it feels extremely one-sided i never
believe her
like i have a friend that is a white
woman who wrote this you better believe
this
i referred that whenever he says argues
his girlfriend
she's always i mean it couldn't be more
rigged against her in terms of like
and then she said this yeah and then
this so it's hard for me yeah but even
discounting this lady let's discount it
a little bit
like it's still awful you know also it's
still
not awful it's just like just tell her
i mean what can she tell her i think
don't make it about any
of this just say you know i just feel
like i
like to do a turnaround i like to blame
myself
like you know what i just feel like
you're displeased with me i feel like
i'm not being a supportive friend
you were upset i wasn't supporting black
women i
you know we don't compromise enough and
i just you know i just do you want to
continue the friendship i mean i don't
want to just be
forever in the doghouse right i don't
know just throw it on yourself
because then what is she gonna do if you
hit her
she's gonna [ __ ] come out by the way
this is a metaphor for the entire
wokeness movement
where you can't there's no right that's
right enough what do you mean
there's no you can't be woke enough for
this woman
you can't be vegetarian enough there's
something going on you can't be
she's just using you're dirty you're
already at
from jump yes you're already you're
gonna lose it's just a matter by how
many yeah and it's not goodbye it's not
fun
no enough you've got mail hello neil
i've been a fan of yours since i saw you
in the daily show
lighten up creep um to be honest i
really didn't know how much i didn't
know much about you had no idea about
your uh
little love chapelle show something
something something something three
mikes but yeah great
well that's nice number one when you get
oh this is bad about you
sorry there's two in a row that are
tough come on get your
get your uh your suit of armor on i have
two upstairs
i've been a no number one when you get
your irish passport neal come on over
there loads of racists
xenophobia alive and well being in the
republic versus the northern [ __ ]
we hate broadly and equally two you may
not like this but
the story from bianca didn't post anyone
in a good light
ireland is as full of [ __ ] women as
the rest of the world
who feels great after spending six to
seven hours flying
from the usa to dublin from the sound of
it bianca was just
being uh a g
was being as much of a g-bag g-bag
there's a asterisk and then it says
g-bag is not a compliment
as the other passenger uh to call her a
racist is a [ __ ] move in ireland or
anywhere outside of the u.s or the uk
that's not warranted or acceptable just
my opinion now
let me handle this bum for you thank you
neil when you get your irish passport
come on over there are loads of racist
xenophobia alive and well so
and then he says like hey don't be
don't call people racist that's my job
in the in
three sentences ago and he also there's
obviously a rivalry with the
republic versus the north carolina shits
on them
northern [ __ ] hey gavin his name's
gavin which is very irish
government
um well first of all gavin have several
seats because
this wasn't like i didn't say i didn't
want to say the story because i
knew i was like this is not a great
story i don't i like the story the story
was fine i think it was funny
it's whatever i can laugh about it but
um
the idea that says to call her a racist
is a [ __ ] move in ireland
or anywhere else outside the us or uk
he just said come on over there to loads
of racists
he used it as a selling point and he's
like
hey [ __ ] there's no racist in ireland
that's right
all it was this was a lady being a
[ __ ] she wasn't being racist
and then i was being i was like okay you
want to serve okay
we can vote you were being the friend
from the letter before
that's fine you're using race for your
own means that's your name
what happened was she volleyed her
bitchiness and followed it right back
and then we just kept it in the [ __ ]
world and then she wanted to make it
very weirdly we didn't speak for like
six seconds
or maybe ten to walk and then when we
got to this saying goodbye um flight
attendants that's when she's like
can you believe she did this in our
country you don't behave like this in
our country that's when it was like well
maybe you're not being racist but you're
being some sort of something
something that's like why do we need to
talk about your country my behavior
in your country she said she called me a
[ __ ] you don't behave like this in our
country
when that lady called me a [ __ ] first
so it was like if you want to be petty
like i i too just came off of a six
seven hour flight
so we can be really he was just saying
like hey
nobody was in a good mood but also the
thing is if
this was you know the villains of the
world are
uh white women from the u.s so let's
just plug in a white woman from us
and a nice irish exchange student hold
on somebody wrote a letter about this
okay shall we i have a follow-up
question would you agree that
the middle-aged white woman is the most
hated figure in our culture
yeah and if you do why do you think it
is
oh i just think it's right now because
it's
it's hot because we don't we haven't
really like we said we addressed it
earlier white women have
kind of gotten a bit of like a soccer
mom
they were soccer mommies they were
soccer mommies so sweet
and they've been actually protected and
have given the benefit of the doubt of
being
nice kind not thieves not anything that
no one else has gotten so
i think now it's just i don't know it's
just the
penalties they outed themselves by
voting for trump i think it's
interesting number
in those numbers and i mean it wasn't it
was 55 but they that's like oh you just
told on yourself
okay so the pendulum is going to swing
in your v and now it's like yeah they
don't go in again you don't know what
yeah so if it was a white woman
from florida middle-aged white one from
florida saying
to a irish exchange student you don't
behave like that
in my country no one would be like she
was probably tired
you know we were going to be like what a
racist karen yeah so it's like
and he said he blew this guy blew his
own cover
by opening with like we're racist here
and then he's like i don't really care
who agrees or disagrees
guys you're a g-bang you always do baby
goodbye can't spell gavin without g bag
you've got uh hey neil i'm the love of
my life bianca i don't
like compliments i'm not gonna
compliment you guys wow
not you neil uh although i do want to
say you should be getting
uh what i've been listening to episode
three and last week listening to my bb
tell that story of that hateful lady on
the plane made me understand why her
i love her so much um i often think to
myself
how is someone that gorgeous and funny
and well-traveled not married
so i just want to take a wild stab at
queen bee's last
relationships okay they start off great
like wildly in love that's where he's
wrong
um so it's going great and every day he
asked how your day was and you're
telling him all the stories of how
people are rude to you
and he is always on your side at first
because bet the [ __ ] is great
and i would always be on your side to
love um
but one night you don't give him any
whomp and he is thinking
clearly and he is like baby i love you
but i think you're wrong and you [ __ ]
lost it i gather this because i felt
your wrath and you were telling that
story about the hate-filled woman on the
plane
the way you snapped when that lady who
was probably just trying to cross your
back
the way you snapped is only uh in a few
special people
you're a special snapper you got that
special snapper
i would i would give up my penis for a
year to be dating you and walking behind
you while you're berating some scared
white lady
with taunts of racist just so you could
be like yeah man i'm not going to stop
her that lady gets to go home tonight
uh i don't want that smokey i don't know
what
he lost he changed povs
so if you can take me on a quick stroll
down the last couple of relationships
and what were the biggest fights i would
appreciate it queen bee i guess
you can say do a two-nail okay first of
all
i love how all these white people are
explaining for this woman i'm like
it was not cool i'm not i agree it
wasn't cool
i don't i don't think i don't think it's
the most egregious thing ever i just
felt like gloves are off let's just all
be pet
you want to be petty then we can be
betty i don't think this is a
story that you know don't tell it at my
eulogy
like i'm too late no neil it's too late
don't this isn't like watch me be cool
and suck it to a white woman i think we
both looked ridiculous
she looked ridiculous at the beginning i
looked ridiculous at the end
but at one point you just i don't
i think once you've called a racist
chasing her down the hallway and calling
a race no it wasn't a chase we were all
walking
it was a fast it was the brisk walk to
them okay it wasn't the it wasn't a
passport
no i just kept i said it quietly i was
like you're racist she was like
leave me alone i'm like racist okay
it was like a jerry seinfeld like i
never raised my voice
that doesn't matter the point is look
i'm sharing you guys
a story right you know bad light i share
a bad light story i'm not defending it
it was hilarious and if you're gonna
other me and make me feel like you
[ __ ] foreigner
it's like no no no no not after you
spread your butt cheeks on me
second of all um this is so funny
this is nothing like my religion but i
date
uh traditionally i guess this maybe
isn't
cool or pc anymore but i tend to date
i tend to be more of a guy in the
relationship not
strength or [ __ ] but um frank ocean
what do you mean
not a guy no like uh
they tell me their problems and i'm the
straight man i'm like
oh and don't get me wrong i do complain
when people rude to me
and i'm sure they're like okay you know
whatever that kind of goes with the
territory but a lot of it is
i don't like putting myself on people or
my problems onto people so i'd rather
they're just i'm not comfortable doing
that
so i'd rather you tell me i'd like to
pivot
questions about me become questions
about you and people
are very full of themselves and not no
shade but just
in general who doesn't want someone to
ask them a question so it's a very easy
thing to avoid
um a lot of times you don't tell me your
last name for a while right
five or six dates last name age
it takes me a few years it takes me a
while if i i don't
know we'll meet there i just have a
weird
i don't know i think and it goes down to
just how i was when i was a kid but
i just don't like putting any of my
burdens on people i don't
doesn't mean i don't do it i just don't
want to actively do it and i don't think
you like people knowing [ __ ] about you
yeah my friend always says you're
beyonce private i'm like
no i'm not she's like no you're beyonce
private
it's all a weird what is beyonce private
what is that a reference to uh
like you don't know i'm doing something
and you don't know beyonce until there's
a level of privacy like until there's a
billboard
it's like oh that's what's going on i
just was really shy growing up extremely
shy and my parents thought it was
autistic so
your your friend still does so then so
then uh i think it just
anyways that's that's what it is he was
wrong
also i want you to give up your penis
for a year
just because uh i gotta go good but
let's um there's a couple
this is a good one this is a good one
you've got mayonnaise and er neil and
banks
um lst nar
[Music]
look marriage has its problems but neil
i need you to be fair and admit that
most of your married friends are famous
married guys and not
normal people true famous married guys
even ugly ones have women
throwing themselves at them all the time
so
when they get home and they want their
wives they they want their wives to not
only [ __ ] them but make them feel like
they aren't missing out on
anything
it's so long willful it's the loud it's
so loud
it's crazy i remember when he first i
was like i don't know what to do about
that because he's such a quiet dog i
know
and then he sneaks up until it's too
late
um uh it so when they get home they want
their wives to not only [ __ ] them
but make them feel like they aren't
missing out on anything good point
that's impossible they're they are a
hundred percent missing out on things
uh there is no vagina on the planet that
could take
away that fomo and the desire for other
vaginas especially easily attainable
vaginas that are waiting for them after
the show were sliding into their dms
neil can you admit that your assessment
of men and marriage is unfairly biased
by the fact that most the men you know
have more options than the average guy
binks thank you for defending the ladies
grab that spatula and tell it like it is
she would grab that spatula guys
but she was so openly hateful toward it
that i threw it in the trash
purple tunnel oh my god i
we'll get you something okay we'll get
you a manscape razor you'll see
um will will have christened it um
so okay neil here
that is true but
i want this guy to admit that 90 of the
people you know
should not be married and the sex thing
has nothing to do with options it has to
do it does
the options makes it worse but
i don't think that my famous friends
who have dog walkers it's a tear that
you can never understand
uh my famous friends uh
if their wives you know you can't shoot
an empty gun
so if their wives emptied the chamber
before they left the house
you got no problems you're into sex
addict land which is a whole other thing
and i don't
i only know a few sex addicts
and um they would be cheating on anyone
yeah well what's i mean i don't get it
then
he wants to admit that the difference
between regular guys and
famous guys is the amount of sex they
have access to
which is true um
i've turned down four pieces of sex
since the beginning of this podcast i'm
not kidding
pieces pieces of sex sex piece
um and so i don't
i just think it's a bad institution
and it should be uh
put in the dustbin of history with
totalitarianism and fascism
and and uh mormonism well yeah even like
that
other guy said why how are you not
married
what year is this yeah that's the sign
of a of a valuable woman
is that she is married what's wrong with
him let me take him out
bended knee for you
uh yeah it's embarrassing it's weird so
i don't think
you're right in that but these guys
aren't these guys are not sleeping with
their wives and then sleeping with
somebody else
what happens is yeah their wives stop
sleeping with them because that's what
happens in every marriage well what if
they take them for granted and their
wife
is nice and once i know plenty of dudes
that
no i don't know plenty i know some
situations where
the girl really wants to [ __ ] and the
guy's like okay see you later
my light's off uh don draper
because there is an element of when you
don't have sex enough
and you're relying on one person to give
it to you
you get so dismayed that by the time
they're like i want it not to you're
like
[ __ ] out of here like i got now now you
want i want it all the time
so now i have to make a big [ __ ] uh
uh
uh giant scissors opening
giant scissors on a giant ribbon because
yeah because you want because you oh
thank god
the [ __ ] she's here everyone
we have i know it's a that's why men and
women
should not get married because we have
entirely different ethos
when it comes to sex i mean you're on
the same page even though i kind you
know here's the thing and i always say
this i don't want marriage
i would love a wedding wedding and i
love a dress
i know pantsuit but i just
yeah it just feels very archaic for the
woman i mean
it's essentially your product being sold
that's like the origins of marriage
and now the cherry on top is that we get
to choose a dress
yeah thanks well i thought of a joke
that i haven't done yet which is
when i was playing tennis i saw a woman
in one of those tennis outfits
oh yeah and i just had the thought women
[Music]
women's a lot of women's lives are about
unlocking outfits so like yeah i'll go
sailing and then you picture yourself in
a little sailing outfit
and you're trying to get to un like
wedding dress
unlocked like that yes like that's the
top
level is wedding dress unlocked and men
are trying to get you out of clothes
that's
that's good that's good that's a good
comedy
comedy he's a rocket scientist yes
you could not do that no hello listener
you're going i could do
you could not have done it because i've
been doing 25 years and i just
came up with it on saturday he knows
about art now
uh and narrative so you that is correct
um so so it's
it's silly and it is archaic and
and i also have a joke that i haven't
done yet which is
you know what marriages are they're not
a license to
be wedded they're a license to [ __ ]
in the eyes of god yeah they're licensed
they're [ __ ] licensed from god yeah
like okay you can now [ __ ]
that's that's all that changes imagine
if you had to marry the
first person you [ __ ] yeah that's most
kind of like how maybe your parents
that's definitely my parents
yeah um yeah
until i mean you start i mean whatever
then you think about the first person
fragments like
god damn yeah [ __ ] no yeah
no [ __ ] no [ __ ] [ __ ] no
it's wrong um okay so what okay can we
just play a game
if you had to design marriage redesign
it
it you had to be you and a one person
but design it
what what could you what would be it
would be it would be
uh it would be a supreme court
appointment it wouldn't be for life it
should be
two years tops and then you renew or
don't
but like [ __ ] forever i don't
dude i'm a different i'm different than
i was last podcast yeah
he's so anxious i'm not even i don't
even i have listened to it i don't even
know that dude
i don't even know that dude
um it would basically be a reality show
like do you
agree to but i agree yes but i don't
think you make it
it wouldn't it
would be more marriages if it was a five
year it's like ten times
if if tattoo disappeared in five years
yeah
you'd have a face that's [ __ ] i'll
marry i'll marry you for five years [ __ ]
it
like whatever really really brock had a
funny joke which is
you woman has to consider
halle berry has to consider every
marriage proposal
and [ __ ] she's not [ __ ] anybody but
like if you go i'll marry you should be
like
yeah it's like is this my choose your
own adventure book am i going down this
chapter
yeah what's the yeah it's like it's vi
it's
it's like i'll make if he's rich yeah
how bad could it be
how am i gonna be oh it came and if it
were five years it'd be like a lot of
[ __ ]
it would be five years and it would also
just be
like a settlement yeah you walk away
larry david said a joke one time which
is uh fame is wasted on the married man
yeah which is [ __ ] so good uh all
right it's uh
it's it's i don't have to take this [ __ ]
o'clock
and i don't have to take this [ __ ]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
goodbye